turning overseas now to China is
accusing the U.S of threatening its
National sovereignty and security after
this very scary encounter in the sky the
U.S military says a Chinese fighter jet
came dangerously close to an American
surveillance plane Elizabeth Palmer has
more on the escalating tensions
Pentagon video from Friday shows what it
says was the Chinese fighter jet
approaching and Crossing just 400 feet
in front of the U.S reconnaissance plane
then turbulence rocks the cockpit our
planes were flying in international
airspace on a routine Mission a Chinese
pilot took dangerous action but the
Chinese say the U.S plain had
deliberately intruded on a training
exercise it's not the first close call
like this last December Pentagon video
shows a Chinese fighter apparently
coming within 20 feet of an American
plane these Close Encounters reflect a
basic disagreement over who controls the
airspace over the South China Sea China
says it does the U.S and its allies say
no one does and American military planes
routinely Patrol it to support the
position that it's open to all but this
is no time for risky confrontations
China has just refused to let its
defense minister who's under American
sanction meet the U.S Secretary of
Defense Lloyd Austin this weekend in
Singapore I think that's unfortunate So
currently there is no direct contact
between the Chinese and American armed
forces so that you know we have a way to
talk to the to the Chinese about
incidents like this one that could lead
to miscalculation and misunderstanding
and maybe getting somebody hurt
meanwhile U.S China relations remain
chilly and the Skies over the South
China Sea hotly contested for CBS
mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo